vous venez de créer votre chaîne youtube
voulais avoir plus d'abonnés avoir plus
de vue mais c'est extrêmement difficile
il ya une très grosse concurrence est
pour l'instant votre chaîne youtube ne
décolle pas dans cette vidéo je vous
donnais 10 astuces indispensables pour
créer sa chaîne youtube les masses
fondamental que tout youtuber doit
connaître pour gagner des vues et des
abonnés de plus en plus de chaînes voit
le jour sur youtube et il est
extrêmement difficile de réussir
je partage avec vous toute mes astuces
mes meilleures techniques pour gagner
des vues des abonnés et enfin réussir
sur youtube inscrivez-vous à ma chaîne
est activé la cloche pour ne manquer
aucune vidéo
question du jour est-ce que vous avez
une chaîne youtube si oui de quoi s
quelle part est est-ce que vous avez des
difficultés pour la faire croître pour
gagner de l'audience et pour gagner des
abonnés mettez moi tout en descriptions
j'ai fait curieux de savoir de quoi par
vossen et pouvoir aller jeter un petit
coup d'oeil
youtube est de plus en plus
concurrentiel quels que soient les
sujets il ya du monde de partout il est
très difficile de percer et pourtant la
plupart des youtube heures débutants ne
met pas en place les bonnes pratiques
voici les 10 bonnes techniques et
astuces pour débuter sur youtube pour un
numéro un
définir une stratégie trouvé sa niche
qu'est ce que vous apportez sur youtube
quel est votre cible quelle est votre
plus value quel problème solutionner
vous en gros pourquoi est-ce qu'on
devrait s'abonner à votre chaîne
ça c'est le point le plus important est
la plupart des youtube heures débutants
ne répondent pas à cette question sur
youtube les gens viennent pour trois
raisons principales la première c'est
parce qu'on leur a partagé une vidéo le
deuxième point c'est parce qu'ils
veulent se divertir
ils veulent regarder des vidéos
rigolotes regarder des humoristes
regarder un contenu qui leur plaît et
qui leur permet de passer du temps des
chats rigolo tous contenus là on a tous
déjà vu qu'on le connaît et le troisième
point et on avis qui est le plus
important
les gens vont sur youtube pour trouver
des solutions à des problèmes à des
problématiques et c'est justement là
dessus que vous devez intervenir
qu'est-ce que vous solutionner comme
problème et qu'est ce que vous apportez
comme élément de réponse
quand on commence sur youtube il faut
pas penser très gros il faut pas penser
à vouloir faire quelque chose de très
larges très variés c'est souvent
l'erreur la plus courante et la plus
connue tous ceux qui ont réussi sur
youtube apporter quelque chose de neuf
si vous faites la même chose que vous
pouvez sûr d'une chose vous ne réussirez
jamais trouvé votre niche trouver votre
plus-value solutionner des
problématiques et là vous pourrez
réussir
point numéro 2
trouver son contenu ses expressions clés
maintenant vous savez que vous devez
solutionner un problème de trouver
comment le solutionner et surtout qu'est
ce que les gens recherchent parce que
personne ne vous découvrira si vous
n'êtes pas découvrable on doit pouvoir
vous trouvez dans les résultats de
recherche youtube appartient à google
jusque là je pense que je vous apprends
rien et youtube est le deuxième moteur
de recherche au monde
il faut absolument que vous trouviez ce
que les gens cherchent la première chose
à faire est la plus maline c'est vous
allez dans votre barre de recherche de
youtube et vous commencez à chercher une
question correspond à votre
problématique
imaginons par exemple votre chaîne soit
sur la fitness vous allez chercher
comment avoir des abdos
comment avoir des abdos en 30 jours et
vous allez voir que en commençant taper
comment avoir des abdos
il va y avoir ensuite des termes qui
vont s'ajouter et ces termes là sont des
thématiques sur lesquelles vous allez
faire vos vidéos c'est ce qu'on appelle
la longue traîne et ça va effectivement
vous permettre d'avoir un contenu qui va
se référencer vous pourrez aussi aller
voir sur google adwords et tous on doit
parler un peu plus tard il ya d'autres
outils je dois parler dans de futurs
vidéo il va vous ai trouvé votre
expression clé sur youtube cliquez
dessus et regarder les vidéos qui sont
proposés si les vidéos ont très très
très peu de vue vous pouvez être sûr
qu'ils aient un volume de recherche qui
est extrêmement fin et c'est pas
nécessairement intéressant il faut
absolument que les vidéos qui sont
suggérées et des très gros volumes de
vue ça veut dire qu'il y a un gros
volume de recherche derrière il faut
aussi faire attention parce que souvent
ça peut être des très grosses yen et des
très gros sienne lorsqu'elle publie une
vidéo elles ont forcément tout de suite
beaucoup de vue attention sujet
d'actualité parce que vous allez pouvoir
monter rapidement mais descendre tout
aussi rapidement une fois que le contenu
n'est plus recherchés penser que les
gens vont rechercher quelque chose et
que vous vous devez être au top pour
leur proposer une solution une fois peu
de solutions et là une fois qu'ils l'ont
vu
si votre contenu et hop ils s'abonneront
et c'est comme ça qu'on lance la machine
point numéro 3 savoir raconter des
histoires sur youtube le contenu est roi
c'est le plus important
si vous faites une vidéo et que vous
n'arrivez pas à captiver votre audience
vous n'arrivez pas intéressés vous
pouvez être sûr qu'ils vont regarder le
début et qui vont tout de suite partir
il y a une règle primordiale sur youtube
c'est d'accrocher le spectateur dans les
dix premières secondes commencer par un
contenu ensuite mettez votre intro et
ensuite développer votre contenu une
intro de la durée maximum 5 secondes
si vous êtes une intro de 15 secondes 10
secondes parce que vous vous la trouvez
chouette dites vous bien
on va commencer le visionnage si la
trois est longue vous avez 80% de
chances qu'ils partent directement
commencé à introduire votre contenu
comme je lé fais au début de cette vidéo
en expliquant la problématique qu'est ce
que vous allez apporter comme solution
met une intro si vous ne vous laissez
pas obligatoire et ensuite enchaîné avec
votre contenu point numéro 4 le matériel
vous embêtez pas avec ça aujourd'hui on
a tous des smartphones qui ont des super
résolution qui ont des supers capteurs
et qui font des vidéos extraordinaire la
seule chose que je vous conseille
éventuellement si vous voulez investir
au début c'est d'avoir un bon micro
si vous prenez votre smartphone et que
vous contenter d'utiliser le micro du
smartphone ça va vraiment être pas
terrible du tout pour ça il existe
plusieurs solutions la toute première
c'est de trouver un micro un petit micro
à vous plonger sur votre smartphone ça
c'est un micro road le vidéo mini qui
marche très très bien
si vous utilisez votre smartphone vous
pouvez aussi très bien trouver un petit
trépied comme le trépied est jolie vous
poser leurs smartphones dessus et ça
marche extrêmement bien
et le troisième point qui peut être
aussi intéressant si vous voulez
consacré un petit budget n'était
vraiment pas du gros budget c'est un
éclairage moi j'ai deux pannes ou
d'éclairage qui me suffisent largement
prenez pas du panneau à l'aide si vous
débutez que ça va vous coûter
extrêmement cher je vous mets rien dans
la description aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil vous verrez tout de suite le
matos qui suffit c'est pas la peine
d'investir énormément surtout quand on
débute on peut faire énormément de vue
avec du matériel qui ne coûte vraiment
pas cher
point numéro 5 la production qu'est ce
que va rendre votre vidéo une fois que
vous l'avez montée c'est un point hyper
important il faut un montage dynamique
il faut du rythme si votre vidéo et
ennuyeuse les gens vont décrocher et
vont partir pareil pour acheter du riz
tant que telle et séquences ajouter une
musique derrière si vous voulez trouver
des musiques sympa vous avez en gros
deux solutions pour pas un problème avec
youtube soit vous utilisez la librairie
musique vous retrouverez directement sur
youtube soit vous pouvez utiliser des
plateformes payantes
moi j'utilise épidémique sans qui marche
très très bien un petit abonnement par
mois et vous avez accès à un catalogue
énorme pensez-y
il faut vraiment dynamiser vos vidéos il
faut que quand les gens le regardent ce
soit agréable il faut qu'ils aient un
message mais il faut aussi que goûter ce
soit divertissant ce soit agréable à
regarder si on s'ennuie on part pareil
pour le montage il faut vous trouviez un
système trouver un système de montage
trouver une façon dont vous allez faire
vos vidéos et ça marchera si vous prenez
par exemple américain casino stade qui
cartonne sur internet il a toujours le
même système
une petite intro un time lapse et après
il déroule son
onu il faut vous trouviez votre système
à vous qui correspond à votre niche
correspond à votre audience et ça
marchera point numéro 6 et c'est
probablement l'un des plus importants
référencer vos vidéos correctement comme
je vous le disais il youtube c'est le
deuxième moteur de recherche au monde
il ya énormément de monde dessus
énormément de requête si vous voulez
apparaître dans les résultats de
recherche pouvoir être suggérées il vous
faut forcément une stratégie de
référencement il est impossible
aujourd'hui de débuter sur youtube en
ayant des titres tout simple qui ne
correspondent à aucune expression clé
vous pourrez faire les meilleures vidéos
du monde vous n'aurez strictement aucune
visibilité
c'est aujourd'hui le plus gros problème
sur youtube c'est que la plupart des
créateurs qui débute passe énormément de
temps à faire de belles vidéos à faire
du bon contenu mais par contre ils ont
absolument aucune stratégie de
référencement ce qui fait que leurs
vidéos
elles sont au top elles peuvent être
cartonné mais personne ne saura jamais
il ya quelques éléments indispensables
comme je vous le disais déjà il faut
trouver une expression clé sur laquelle
vous allez vous référence et ça ça va
être la base de votre titre aujourd'hui
youtube référence par pertinence c'est à
dire qu'il faut que votre titre de votre
vidéo corresponde exactement où à
quelque chose près à l'expression que
les gens vont chercher dans youtube vous
l'avez vu que ce soit sur google ou sur
youtube
lorsque vous commencez à taper une
requête de recherche on va vous faire
une suggestion et c'est là dessus que
les gens compliqué ils vont cliquez sur
la suggestion et c'est cette suggestion
que vous devez rentrer dans votre titre
alors pas seulement dans votre titre
il ya deux éléments très importants la
première c'est votre vignette
elle doit vraiment être accrocheuse où
on doit avoir envie de cliquer elle doit
suggérer l'intérêt et la curiosité votre
vignette doit résumer elle seule le
contenu de votre vidéo en voyant votre
ligne est on peut se dire c'est ça que
je veux voir c'est cette vidéo parce que
je suis sûr qu'elle va répondre à ma
question vote il doit être accrocheur
mais dites vous bien qu'au premier ce
qu'on regarde sur les suggestions ou ce
qu'on revienne sur la page d'accueil ce
sont les vignettes et juste après on va
dire les titres votre type de
correspondent donc à votre expression
clé votre vignette doit être accrocheuse
mettez du tech quelque chose de
dynamique punchy avec du contraste il
faut qu'elle se démarque des autres et
que tout de suite on comprenne de quoi
ça parle
autre point hyper important et qui est
vraiment sous-estimé c'est la
description vous devez écrire un texte
dans votre description pas forcément
pour les gens le regard parce qu'il est
très clair que les gens ne le regarde on
pas ça permet tout simplement à youtube
de comprendre de quoi parle votre ville
il faut que vous mettiez votre
expression clé et votre mot clé
principale dans la première partie du
texte et ensuite tous les mots clés que
vous mettrez dans la partie daiza partie
mots clés en dessous on doit aller
retrouver dedans si vous voulez avoir
une chance d'être référencé il faut
effectivement qu'on les retrouve dans
votre description votre description ça
ne va pas et du spam ce ne doit pas être
une liste de mots clés
ça doit être un texte rédigé quelque
chose qui est bien fait vous reprenez un
peu le contenu de vos vidéos et vous
taper tout ça là dedans attention par
contre ça doit pas être fourre-tout vous
devez pas en mettre tout le temps il
faut considérer que vous ayez à peu près
1% un ennemi pour cent de mots clés
mettez votre mot clé principale au début
au milieu ou à la fin les autres
expressions un pas à droite à gauche et
comme ça vous aurez une chance de
réussir autre point important ce sont
les taxes les taxes les mots clés que
vous allez avoir en dessous ça permettra
effectivement à youtube de comprendre de
quoi parle votre vidéo et sur quels mots
clés vous positionner alors attention ne
mettez pas tout c'est pas fort tout ça
sert à rien de mettre le maximum mais tu
es vraiment ce qui est pertinent si par
exemple fait une vidéo sur comment terme
du poids regardez ce que vous propose
youtube dans la barre de recherche
dans ce cas là vous pourriez m comment
perdre du poids dans vos taxes comment
perdre du poids rapidement
commentaire du pont en 30 jours vous
pourriez aussi marqué commande ainsi
recommandé greer et défier besoin d
expression un peu plus longue que des
mots clés simple si un mot clé vous
mettez malgré mincir terme du poids ça
ne sert quasiment à rien lorsque vous
débutez concentrez vous sur ce que les
gens recherchent sur ce qu'ils vont
réellement taper et cliquez sur youtube
septième point engagé et interagir il
est très très important dans vos vidéos
de poser des questions à votre audience
pour qu'ils interagissent son
commentaire demandez leur de laisser des
pouces demandez leur de s'abonner mais
sa monnaie pour une raison précise vous
solutionner un problème
et s'ils veulent avoir d'autres
solutions il faut qu ils s'abonnent les
commentaires c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir des commentaires posez-leur une
question directement dans votre vidéo
posez leur des questions sur la
thématique est ce que vous aimez ci est
ce que vous aimez ça qu'elle est ce que
vous pensez de ça et interagissent et
répondait à tous les commentaires autre
point qui peut être intéressant mettez
vous même un commentaire est pingre et
le en vous poser une question qu'est ce
que vous pensez de sic est ce que vous
pensez de ça et vous quel est votre
meilleure méthode pour perdre du poids
qu est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé
qu'est ce qui marche selon vous fait
interagir votre audience pour avoir des
commentaires parce que ça fait aussi
partie de stratégie de référencement
plus vous avez d'interaction des pousses
dans
o des commentaires des partages et plus
votre vidéo va se référencer autre point
important sur youtube et qui fait
souvent le succès des chèques c'est la
collaboration
c'est extrêmement difficile au début
parce qu'on n'a pas d'audience et on
trouve personne avec qui collaborer
le secret de la collaboration c'est de
trouver des gens qui sont dans votre
thématique et qui ont sensiblement le
même nombre d'abonnés vous si dès le
départ vous allez voir des gens qui ont
des centaines des milliers d'abonnés
il est très clair qu'il ne vous
répondrons pas et pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont extrêmement sollicités
soyez réalistes trouver des personnes
qui sont dans la même thématique que
vous qui seront intéressés pour
collaborer avec vous et à qui vous allez
apporter quelque chose quand vous
demandez une collaboration quelqu'un dit
pas simplement es tu faire une
collaboration
proposez-lui un projet c'est comme ça
que vous pourrez attirer des
collaborateurs qui seront éventuellement
un peu plus gros que vous mais comme je
vous l'aï dit il faut garder une
certaine proportion sinon ça ne marchera
pas un mot que vous une idée de génie ou
quelqu'un bravo une collaboration doit
être profitable pour vous et pour la
personne en face faut toujours avoir ça
en tête ça c'est super important au
numéro 9 mettre en forme votre chaîne
comment est-ce qu'on va vous découvrir
quelqu'un va trouver votre vidéo dans
les résultats de recherche ou dans les
suggestions à ce moment là ils vont la
regarder et s'y trouve que vous êtes
intéressant il ya très très peu de
chances qu'ils aient cliquer sur
s'abonner directement la plupart du
temps ils vont cliquez sur votre pseudo
ils vont arriver sur votre page et là
ils pourront s'abonner par contre si
votre page elle est naze si votre page
allait mal conçu si votre page propose
un contenu qui fait pas du tout
professionnelle
alors qu'il répond pas du tout à la
problématique qu'ils ont vu c'est le cas
par exemple si vous avez une chaîne qui
va parler de plein de choses différentes
il faut vraiment que votre chaîne elle
est une thématique et une seule une
thématique forte sinon il faut qu'ils
aient des liens
il faut qu'ils aient des bons en train
l'ifo qui ait un sens et il faut ensuite
cantonale soit votre chaise elle est un
aspect pro on parle pas d'en faire trop
on parle juste de compréhension il faut
que votre photo soit clair qu'elle vous
représentent qu'elles soient bien que
votre bannière explicite bien ce que
vous faites quand les pompes a pas
forcément d'avoir un graphisme de fou
mais juste de comprendre qui vous êtes
ce que vous faites et à quels problèmes
vous répondez ça c'est extrêmement
important
après sur votre chaîne il faut que vous
organisez votre chaîne en playlist vous
mettez des playlists sur les grandes
thématiques que vous allez traiter et
vous allez voir qui aura une vraie
compréhension et à ce moment là les gens
vont s'abonner
autre point très important ne négligez
pas la vidéo de présentation fait une
vidéo de présentation très clair dans
laquelle vous explique
et qui vous êtes ce que vous faites pour
quoi pour le fait est qu est ce que vous
allez apporter quelques problèmes
auxquels vous répondez est comme ça vous
verrez vous à les convertir vos vues en
abonnés point numéro 10 promouvoir son
contenu vous avez une chaîne youtube qui
est top
maintenant vous avez dû contenu mais il
faut le promouvoir parce que pour
l'instant et youtube ne vous place pas
dans les résultats de recherche va
mettre un petit peu de temps pour vous
indexé va vous tester sur différentes
requêtes pour ensuite pouvoir gagner en
vue et ensuite convertir on abonnés mais
dans un tout premier temps vous allez
devoir promouvoir poids contenu par vous
même sur facebook sur twitter
instagram snapshot et tous les réseaux
sociaux qui correspondent à votre niche
sur facebook invitait tous vos amis à
venir découvrir votre travail ce seront
vos premiers abonnés ce sont des vrais
amis ils viendront s'abonner sur twitter
trouvaient les hashtag qui sont
importants dans votre niche les hashtag
qui marche afin de pouvoir être
découverts et qu'on puisse venir voir
votre contenu pareil sur instagram
il ya des groupes sur facebook sur
lesquels vous pouvez interagir s'il ya
des groupes qui existent par rapport à
votre niche aller dedans discuter avec
eux essayé de solutionner les problèmes
des gens et ensuite d'introduire le fait
que vous avez une chaîne et qui peut
éventuellement les aider faites la même
chose sur les forums trouver des forums
correspondent à des problèmes aux gens
qui ont des problèmes par rapport à
votre problématique sur youtube je vous
invite à aller voir des chaînes qui sont
dans votre thématique et de répondre aux
commentaires
la plupart des chaînes youtube surtout
les plus grosses n'ont pas de réponses à
leurs commentaires et non pas de
réponses à leurs problèmes
allez-y et répondez vous verrons ce que
ces gens là vont venir consulter votre
page
et pourquoi pas s'abonner à votre chaîne
c'est un très très bon moyen pour
acquérir l'audience quand on débute sa
chaîne youtube un point extrêmement
important ne fait pas de spams
n'envoyez pas juste je viens de voter
dans dix ans c'est super des abonnés tu
à voir et surtout ne faites pas de
soldes fort seul ça ne sert à rien ne
dites surtout pas abonnez vous à ma
chaîne jeunes à vaudrey à la vôtre ça ça
ne marche pas au contraire c'est un
point négatif c'est un élément négatif
ça veut dire que personne ne vienne
naturellement ce abonner à notre chaîne
et ça veut dire que votre contenu et
probablement sans intérêt ne faites
surtout pas ça ça ne sert à rien et si
toutefois vous aviez des gens qui
voulaient s'abonner à votre chaîne
il ne s'agirait pas dépôt de contenu ça
veut dire qu'ils ne s'intéressent pas
votre contenu ils vont pas mettre de
pouce ils ne vont pas les regarder voûté
n'y aurait pas de vue vous aurez une
chaîne avec un compteur qui sera un peu
plus haut mais sans aucune interaction
ça servira strictement rien il vaut
mieux avoir une chaîne avec moins
d'abonnés mais des abonnés qui
interagissent
abonnés qui s'intéressent à ce que vous
faites plutôt qu'avoir un très gros
compteurs avec des gens qui ne regardent
pas qu'ils ne s'intéressent pas ça ne
sert strictement à rien voilà un peu les
10 points essentiels pour débuter votre
chaîne youtube
surtout ne vous découragez pas au début
ça prend du temps il faut être
référencés mais si vous appliquer
scrupuleusement ses 10 points
si vous faites attention si vous
réfléchissez si vous êtes malin que vous
avez une niche que vous respectez votre
communauté que vous comprenez comment
marche études et comment marcher le
référencement vous allez réussir
il n'y a pas de raison que ça ne marche
pas pour ma part je vous invite à
laisser un pouce et cette vidéo vous a
intéressé si elle vous apporter des
éléments de réponse
abonnez vous à ma chaîne si vous voulez
savoir comment développer votre chaîne
comment développer votre audience et
réussir sur youtube il va y avoir
énormément contenues dans ce sens pour
vous aider à réussir votre chaîne
pour ma part je vous dis à très bientôt
merci d'avoir regardé et portez vous
bien
salut